what's the difference between story and
information
information allows us to construct a
lens for seeing the
world story allows us to experience the
world information is processed in a
certain part of our brain that deals
with
logic story is processed in a part of
our brain that deals with emotions with
feelings and as much as we would like to
think that we make decisions in life
based on
information I would suggest we make
decisions in life based on feelings
based on emotion and then we go looking
for evidence to support those
things so if we think about what drives
human decision making I believe story is
much more active in our decision-making
process of moving through the world than
information I may have all the good
information in the world about something
but if my gut tells me do
this I usually am going to listen to my
God in the same way
um I've seen a lot of wonderful
documentary
stories that provide me information
about about certain ways I should eat
certain ways I should exercise certain
ways that I should live and I'm
compelled by that
information but rarely has it ever
caused me to change my
behavior but a good
story that has caused me to change my
behavior before I've been compelled by
someone's
story perhaps another way of looking at
it is the fact that
information is in the do domain of
things facts figures numbers stories are
in the domain of
people have you ever heard of a story
that didn't have at least one
character I don't think it exists I
don't think we can have a story without
at least one character even if that
character is a tree or a rock it takes
on some sort of personified presence and
becomes a character in the story stories
are innately connected to humans to
people information not so much
information can be about completely
inanimate
things stories are always going to
involve some aspect of humanity The
Human
Experience what's the difference between
framework and storytelling the framework
of a story are those things things which
the story hang
upon many times I found that
storytellers become very nervous when it
comes to discussions around framework
many storytellers become nervous that
they're going to somehow be Boxed In by
using structure in a storytelling or
using some sort of
framework we seem to be the only um
artists who get greatly concerned about
this I've never
once encountered a musician who said you
know I'm just not going to use any of
the existing musical notes that are out
there I'm going to invent my own new
musical note I've never encountered a um
a painter who said you know I'm not
going to use any variation of the
primary colors just not going to do it
going to invent new colors I've never
met a um an architect that said I'm
going to go build a house but no
blueprint none not going to use one just
going to build it also I don't want a
house that has a ceiling or a floor or
Windows or walls or doors don't want any
of that stuff in
there but we as storytellers often
completely reject these elements of the
framework that makes the story
effective now does that mean that every
story needs to be Alik no in the same
way that not every house is alike right
we can build a house with the same you
know floor and ceiling and windows and
doors but that house can look completely
different is every song alike because
they may use the same notes is every
work of art the same because you might
use similar colors or the same colors in
it
no in the same way we must learn to
embrace framework as storytellers
because it is not for us
here's the the hard truth about
storytelling as storytellers we don't
tell stories for us we tell it for
others we don't Embrace framework for us
we Embrace framework for those who will
encounter the stories we create how do
we know if our story is
Meandering many storytellers run into
this issue where they are working out
the story as they're telling
it this can lead to Meandering not
always we have to be in touch with
ourself uh to to recognize the type of
Storyteller that we are some of us like
to craft and construct the story as
we're telling it but rarely is that the
version of the story that we should be
taking to an
audience many times we are going to need
to work with that clay further before we
want to bring it out to others now I
recognize we live in an age uh where we
celebrate every thing we ever do
creatively and many of us uh will put
everything we ever do up on
YouTube
but to be honest with you I wonder what
our art might be
like if we considered 80 90% of what we
create of what we write of what we film
to be practice for that 10% that we
bring out in the
world again if we turn turn to other
crafts we look at a a um a symphony
orchestra
violinist she very well may spend 90% of
her time practicing the
violin in rooms that no one will ever
see her in order for that 10% that goes
up on the stage to be excellent
so often as writers and storytellers we
forget this is a craft and a craft is
dependent upon our
practice and the more that we practice
the better we get at the
craft and we don't have to
necessarily uh bring everything we do uh
up to the audience my
opinion we should be taking what we do
finding the appropriate and proper
framework for that story which may take
a process it may take development but
once we have it only then do we bring it
out and share it with the
world how do people use story to make
sense of the world human beings have
been using story to make sense of the
world since we were first able to
articulate anything even before
language when people people were still
creating images on the walls of caves
somehow story was coming
out people have used story to make sense
of the world because part of the human
experience is recognizing that there is
Mystery that we don't know what's
happening here we don't know if there's
something greater than us something
Beyond us and we're trying to work it
out we're all doing the best we can to
work through these issues that we all
seem to share as human
beings and trying to come to some sense
of what it
means what does it mean to be alive what
does it mean to be conscious what does
it mean to be
human is there a difference between what
you are seeing and experiencing in the
world and what I am seeing and
experiencing in the
world is is the color that you call blue
the color that I call Red and we just
trade names for
it we don't know anything except for our
own
experience and that leaves us insecure
it leaves us
unsure but our comfort comes from
exchanging stories telling each other
the stories that we have about the way
the world looks to
us and even when we don't get it right
we hear each other's stories and we
say I take comfort in that I feel better
because what you said it resonates with
me and it makes me feel like
maybe I am not alone
here I would suggest you the
Grand achievement of any great
Storyteller is making someone feel a
little less alone in the
world